bonsoir merci de nous rejoindre sur tv
fil 78 pour une nouvelle édition du
journal de la rédaction le 7-8 lac tu
vois si les titres de ce mercredi 16
octobre jean paul huchon annonce 70000
logements supplémentaires par an de
nouvelles gares et 28 mille emplois de
plus par an toujours d'ici à 2030 l
assemblée régionale d'île de france doit
se prononcer lors d'un vote ce vendredi
retour sur la présentation qui s'est
tenu en début de semaine de la ligne qui
reliera viroflay à châtillon en passant
par vélizy mise en service du thé 6 à
partir de 2014 le chantier s'achèvera en
2015 deux départements sont concernés
les élus étaient tous présents pour
cette première inauguration à vélizy et
parle d'événements historiques et puis
le professeur jean-daniel chiche
professeur de réanimation à l'hôpital
cochin au fondateur de la fondation live
priority et qui participent à la journée
européenne de lutte contre les arrêts
cardiaques sera l'invité du journal la
journée de lutte contre les arrêts
cardiaques se dérouler ce 16 octobre à
l'image du jour à présent c'est la
fermeture annoncée celle de l'enseigné
bricorama à montigny le bretonneux à la
direction indiquait être victime de la
concurrence de l'enseignent leroy merlin
le dimanche situés sur le même secteur à
bois d'arcy une autorisation dominical
dont ce magasin de centre ville ne
disposait en revanche pas bricorama
montigny le bretonneux perdait 100 mille
euros par mois selon le président du
groupe on écoute c'est la réaction de
quelques clients ce matin à l'annoncé de
cette fermeture programmée
j'étais au courant mais c'est dommage
parce que c'est un magasin de proximité
quoi donc ça permet de dépanner très
facilement
c'est dommage moi personnellement je
viens jamais le dimanche matin j en
semaine mais je trouve que c'est dommage
pour les gens qui bat qui viennent qui
sont contents d'avoir ce magasin
ouvert ce jour là c'est un magasin qui
est très pratique pour les gens qui
comme moi habitons à trac bodart si mon
tennis est le seul magasin dans le coin
on puisse trouver bas tout ce que l'on
veut en détail un bricorama qui ferme à
montigny le bretonneux nouvelle
illustration du bras de fer entre les
enseignes autour de cette question de
l'ouverture du dimanche le reportage à
présent de yolaine thorez et les
d'elodie moines
au mois de décembre ce magasin bricorama
de montigny le bretonneux sera désormais
fermé privé d'ouverture le dimanche
depuis près d'un an le magasin a vu son
chiffre d'affaires diminuer nous
constatons que nous n'avons pas de
report des ventes que nous avions le
dimanche sur le samedi notamment et que
les clients qui puisque ils ont la
possibilité et l'opportunité d'aller
chez leroy merlin et castorama qui eux
restent ouverts le dimanche eh bien nous
on n'a pas de report de ventes sur les
autres jours de la semaine une
concurrence que le magasin jugent
déloyale leroy merlin et castorama à
proximité ont en effet obtenu une
dérogation pour rester ouverts le
dimanche selon le président du groupe
bricorama depuis la fermeture le
dimanche le magasin perdait 100 mille
euros par mois un magasin qui emploie 23
salariés l'objectif de la direction est
de zéro licenciement
les salariés notre volonté c'est de les
replacer dans d'autres magasins du
groupe sur la région parisienne
sylvie travaille depuis 23 ans dans ce
magasin cette nouvelle elle s'y
attendait plus ou moins au départ on
devait rétrécir le le magasin donc après
surprise oui oui et non pas parce que
quand on est ancien plus l'ouverture du
magasin dans quand c'est sûr j'aurais
préféré qui rétrécissent le magasin
c'est sur mais bon c'est comme ça c'est
les travaux coûtait trop cher le chiffre
d'affaires n'était pas là n'était pas au
rendez vous donc c'est normal c'est très
très dur mais bon on va nous reclasser
donc je pense qu'il n'y aura pas de
soucis quoi j'ai un peu peur d'aller
travailler par exemple à paris prendre
les transports en commun et aux c'est
sûr mais je n'aurais peut-être pas le
choix non plus vva moi j'ai demandé au
plus près parce qu'on nous a déjà déjà
demandé où on voulait travailler donc
j'ai demandé au plus près le premier
j'avais demandé voisins après j'ai
demandé rambouillet et après s'il ya pas
bah ça sera
ce sera dans d'autres magasins on verra
bien
d'autres en revanche semble beaucoup
plus inquiet quant à leur avenir
emmanuel lui n'a pour le moment reçu
aucune promesse de reclassements je suis
pas sûr de retrouver toutes les boules
au goût du jour au lendemain
j'ai rejeté ne plus avoir de boulot
sur la peur
l'impact de la fermeture dominicale
pourrait ne pas s'arrêter là deux autres
magasins également dans le rouge serait
aussi menacé celui de
voisins-le-bretonneux n'est pas concerné
par une fermeture
et pour clarifier ces règles de
l'ouverture le dimanche rappelons que le
gouvernement a commandé un rapport à
l'ancien dirigeant de la poste jean paul
bailly ses conclusions seront connues
d'ici la fin du mois de novembre de
cette année quel visage pour l'île de
france en 2030 jean paul huchon annonce
70000 logements supplémentaires par an
de nouvelles gares 28 mille emplois de
plus également par an le schéma
directeur de la région ile-de-france
sera soumis au vote vendredi de
l'assemblée régionale un sujet de
florian philippe pour nos confrères de
votv
affrontement gauche droite au conseil
régional d'ile-de-france sur le sdrif le
document qui dessinent le visage de la
région 10 y à 2030 pour l'ump ce drif
n'est pas acceptable il repose sur le
projet du métro automatique du grand
paris un dossier pour lequel l'état n'a
pas mis le milliards manquants sur la
table moi je vous attention danger ce
schéma directeur qui permet aux maires
d'urbaniser et de créer de l'emploi
partout en ile de france c'est des
embouteillages cd rom air saturé ces des
lignes de train qui ne tiendront pas le
chat pour l'ump la non inscription du
milliard d'euros par l'état pour le
grand paris pose la question de la
légitimité de ce nouveau sdrif une
motion de rejet était déposée par
valérie pécresse du côté de la majorité
de gauche on maintient le cap il est
nécessaire de renouveler le sdrif dès
maintenant l'enjeu c'est de sortir d'un
schéma directeur qui datent de 94 on
vous imaginez un petit peu
l'obsolescence des documents et c'est de
faire en sorte de répondre à des défis
qui sont là défi très très concrets
comme on se loge comment on se nourrit
comment on travaille le sdrif a suscité
le dépôt de plus de 300 amendements la
gauche disposant de la majorité le sdrif
devrait être votée sans difficulté
toutefois son adoption et son
approbation ne devrait pas intervenir
avant la fin de l'année 2013 à l'issue
d'une enquête publique qui doit débuter
en mars 2013
la mort subite première cause de
mortalité des moins de 50 ans en france
est pourtant de bons réflexes
permettrait de sauver de nombreuses vies
aujourd'hui première journée européenne
de sensibilisation à l'arrêt cardiaque
et je reçois pour le 7 8 sélections
daniel schick bonsoir vous êtes le
professeur de réanimation à l'hôpital
cochin à paris fondateur de la fondation
live priority également vous ouvrez pour
le progrès la reconnaissance de la
réanimation à travers toute l'europe
avec notamment aussi une campagne de
sensibilisation gratuite aux gestes qui
sauvent à travers l'europe on va donner
d'ailleurs quelques chiffres sur 350
milles arrêt cardiaque seulement 3%
survivre sans séquelle neurologique
majeur et ce faute de pratique de ces
gestes qui sauvent ça semble une
évidence il faut les apprendre et
pourtant sans arrêt il faut rabâcher
régulièrement qu'il est la nécessité
d'apprendre ces gestes qui sauvent
pourquoi il n'y a pas de déclic et
pourquoi n'y a pas de progression dans
l'apprentissage de ses gestes la logique
serait d'apprendre dès le plus jeune âge
ou
enfants probablement dans le cadre
scolaire ou dans les activités
périscolaires
ces gestes qui sauvent qui sont déjà
c'est extrêmement simple est il que
n'importe qui un enfant peut apprendre
de fait si malheureusement tu as fait et
lorsque ces gestes sont enseignés c'est
souvent enseigné au sein de formation
qui dure 24 ou 48 heures et où les
messages sont nombreux et des messages
nombreuses c'est peut-être pas
nécessairement la meilleure façon de
faire passer le message le plus
important est ce message important c'est
reconnaître un arrêt cardiaque y faire
des gestes très très simple très simple
mais qui peuvent faire la différence
entre effectivement la survie sans
séquelle neurologique ldc il faudrait
faudrait rendre obligatoire ces cours de
premiers secours absolument on pourra
imaginer qu'à chaque examen important
gay c'est une épreuve qu'ils en fassent
partie au bac les différents brevets
elle permis de conduire on pourrait
imaginer
effectivement que ça devienne une
formation civique obligatoire parce que
l'arrêt cardiaque concerne tout le monde
on aurait plutôt tendance à penser aux
hommes de plus de 60 ans en général
d'image la description qui revient mais
ce n'est pas le cas ça touche tout le
monde pas seulement effectivement pas
seulement le dernier arrêt cardiaque
arrivé dans notre service à l'hôpital
cochin c'est un jeune homme de 20 ans
sportif qui a fait 1 un accident
cardiaque à l'arrivée des 20 km de paris
donc alors qu'ils étaient sportifs
entraînés donc ça touche ça peut toucher
n'importe qui et encore une fois ses
gestes aussi sont à la portée de
n'importe qui vous avez décidé
d'intervenir avec votre fondation live
priority pour enseigner ces gestes qui
sauvent pas uniquement d'ailleurs
puisque vous aurez autour de la
réanimation on va en parler mais sur ces
gestes qui sauvent déjà sur la création
de cette fondation qu'est ce qui vous a
motivé qu'est-ce qui vous êtes décidé à
mettre en place une si grosse structure
parce que vous vous déplacez à travers
toute l'europe vous avez un camion pour
aller apprendre ses gestes et des
animations qui sont organisées à travers
toute l'europe
en fait un des parrains de la fondation
c'est eric abidal le sportif et en
discutant avec eric on s'est rendu
compte que lui-même n'était n'est pas
formé et on s'est dit que aller par
exemple à la rencontre des sportifs des
supporters c'était une façon peut-être
assez simple de sensibiliser les gens la
réanimation dans la mesure où la
réanimation c'est un peu la médecine
générale des détresses vitales et
finalement le citoyen c'est le premier
maillon de cette chaîne de survie donc
on a décidé avec eric de mettre en place
cette campagne qui s'appelait louis
zavlav qui a conduit la priorité autour
des stades d'europe autour de six pays
visités 11 villes ça c'est pour les
chevaux et ses dernières éditions
s'étaient pour les chiffres de la
dernière édition mais effectivement on a
été présents autour de ça de football
d'édition la dernière édition du
marathon de paris
le tour d'espagne on va à la rencontre
du public qui intervenait régulièrement
ailleurs vous êtes intervenu dans les
yvelines à buc injustement pour
apprendre ces gestes qui sauvent c'était
au sein d'une entreprise ge healthcare
qui travaillent avec vous justement et
qui travaillent autour des solutions
animations en cardiologie qui travaille
avec la priorité absolue mandji al khair
c'est un partenaire important de la
réanimation et c'était assez amusant
d'aller former finalement d'aider des
gens qui travaillent dans une entreprise
très impliqué dans le domaine de la
santé et qui eux mêmes n'étaient pas
nécessairement formé la grande majeure
partie des salariés n'étaient pas formés
aujourd'hui on était avec les écoles de
football du paris saint germain
encore une fois allons rencontrer notre
public nos citoyens les plus jeunes
générations pour leur apprendre des
gestes très très simple et la question
qui revient sans doute le plus souvent
vous l'avez évoqué d'ailleurs au début
de cet entretien c'est comment on
reconnaît un arrêt cardiaque pas c'est
très simple si quelqu'un qui ne répond
pas et qui ne respire pas cela suffit
pour faire le diagnostic d'arrêt
cardiaque est en tout cas décidé que
cette personne va avoir besoin des
manoeuvres de réanimation les les plus
simples qui font la différence
personne ne répond pas personne ne
respire pas pas la peine de chercher le
pouls ça suffit pour prendre votre
téléphone vers un numéro en france le 15
ou le 112
tenez votre localisation diro
permanenciers du samu qu'effectivement
vous êtes en présence de quelqu'un ne
répond pas ne respire pas et vous
démarrez tout de suite les gestes qui
sauvent et ses gestes qui sauvent c'est
le massage cardiaque et ses gestes qui
sauvent ce massage cardiaque savez vous
le pratiquez savez-vous réagir si
justement devant vous constatez un arrêt
cardiaque voici quelques réactions micro
trottoir réalisé aujourd'hui
j'avais fait un diplôme de secourisme
une époque donc j'ai su à une époque
maintenant moyens quoi déjà j'appelle
les pompiers voilà et puis je le mets
sur le côté ouais sur le
sur la gauche appeler des secours mais
ils à mettre au moins en position
sur le côté pour pas qu'elle avale sa
langue et ses vérifier le pouls massage
cardiaque et chercher le défibrillateur
j'appelle réalise court sachant que j'ai
pas la formation nécessaire pour lui
porter assistance seul donc chez qu'il
ya des compagnies avec des
défibrillateurs qui se met en place je
pense que ça doit être généralisé pour
que et nous mêmes formes et les sites et
enfin fort mais aussi les citoyens pour
que ce soit efficace aussi
si on ne sait pas pratiquer le massage
cardiaque qui a tout même des gestes à
faire des automatismes des réactions à
avoir là un geste à prendre de massage
cardiaque c'est simplissime c'est très
très simple et ce micro trottoir est
très intéressant parce qu'il montre un
certain nombre d'idées reçues la
position latérale de sécurité ne met pas
en sécurité des malades dont le coeur et
tarik quelqu'un qui ne répond pas il ne
respire pas la seule vraie position
c'est à plat dos et on démarre ce
massage cardiaque il n'y a aucun danger
vous ne risquez pas de faire du mal à un
patient qui est décédé si vous
n'intervenez pas massage cardiaque quand
ce massage cardiaque comme cette récente
il rappelé avait les mains posé les
mains sur le sternum par la ligne qui
passe au milieu du thorax entre l'imam
l'eau et vous allez bras tendus
pratiquer des compressions thoraciques
en déprimant la cage thoracique en
enfonçant la cage thoracique d'environ 5
cm c'est sans danger même si vous cassez
une côte ça n'est pas grave et avoir une
côte cassée nous réalisateur nous en
ferons notre affaire mais c'est comme ça
que vous allez sauver des vies depuis
2006 il ya eu quelques cent mille
défibrillateur qui ont été installés
dans les lieux publics est ce que ça a
changé quelque chose ça a servi à
quelque chose ça sert forcément à
quelque chose il est important constaté
que d'abord ces défibrillateurs ne sont
pas toujours très facilement accessible
parce qu'ils sont parfois placés dans
des institutions fermées à clé après 18
heures les gens ont peur d'utiliser ces
défibrillateurs alors que c'est sans
danger un enfant de 5 6 ans sait se
servir d'un défibrillateur de façon
totalement efficace vous ne risquez pas
de vous électrocuté vous ne risquez pas
d'électrocuter la victime c'est très
simple mais encore une fois ça ne suffit
pas il ya des données très récente qui
montre qu'en si vous prenez l'arrêt
cardiaque au cours de la pratique
sportive par exemple des gens qui font
du sport pour s'amuser le taux de survie
varie d'un département à l'autre de 0,3
à 43% et ce qui explique ces variations
inacceptable confiné ce qui explique ces
variations c'est la qualité de la
formation pas l'accès un défibrillateur
on en revient à votre action puisque le
but aussi de la priorité votre fondation
c'est de sensibiliser à la réanimation
aussi c'est une spécialité qui n'est
connu la réanimation c'est vrai ma mère
ne sais pas ce que je fais la
réalisation c'est en fait quoi en
réanimation à l'enfant en réanimation on
va vous prendre en charge si votre vie
est menacée parce qu'un des organes de
vos organes ne fonctionne pas bien
quelle que soit la maladie qui va
menacer votre vie vous allez être pris
en charge par une équipe de réanimation
c'est vraiment un sport d'équipé dans
l'animation et on va d'une part
s'assurer de faire fonctionner ces
organes ou remplacer ses organes
temporairement pas un respirateur par
une machine d'hémodialyse si votre rat
ne marche pas traiter la maladie qui
vous a mis dans cette situation et
essayer de faire en sorte que vous
accédiez après à ce qu'on peut appeler
une seconde vie donc c'est si je dois
résumé ça en une phrase c'est la
médecine générale et la médecine
générale des détresses vitales qui doit
intervenir rapidement
de façon coordonnée et en équipe et vous
avez des parrains des célébrités qui
vous soutiennent un chaque année vous
avez mentionné éric abidal cette année
c'est sinclair je crois sinclair cet art
y effectivement de nos deux noms pareils
nous soutient une dernière question
puisque nous sommes donc département des
yvelines elle concerne la société carmat
qui est implantée à vélizy elle
développe un coeur artificiel qui minent
leur gamme naturel avec des capteurs des
microprocesseurs vous êtes forcément au
courant de toutes ces technologies l'a
beaucoup mieux que nous la karma qui
avait obtenu l'autorisation d'être
implantés ces coeurs artificiels sur
quatre patients en france fin septembre
les résultats seront connus d'ici la fin
de l'année c'est une véritable
révolution il avancé votre réaction
oui c'est une avancée indiscutable dont
le le sens où aujourd'hui le
l'alternative lorsqu'on souffre de
défaillance cardiaque extrêmement sévère
d'insuffisance cardiaque sévère c'est la
transplantation on entend souvent parler
transplantation et chaque fois qu'on
parle de transplantation on parle de
disponibilité des griffons avoir
aujourd'hui des coeurs artificiels qui
permettent soit d'attendre un greffon
soit idéalement un jour de vivre avec
ces coeurs artificiels
ça a été une avancée spectaculaire et
aujourd'hui ça a transformé d'ores et
déjà le pronostic de ces malades avec
des insuffisances cardiaques sévères là
aussi ça se passe en réanimation après
la chirurgie bon alors on en sait un
petit peu plus déjà sur la réanimation
sur votre spécialité merci jean daniel
si je rappelle que vous êtes aussi
fondateur de cette fondation live
priorité c'était aujourd'hui la première
journée européenne de l'arrêt cardiaque
merci à vous merci bien premier essai
pour la nouvelle rame de tramway qui
doit relier viroflay à châtillon en
passant par les yvelines offrir ainsi
une gare à vélizy un pôle économique
majeur le site de maintenance installés
dans les yvelines vient d'être inaugurée
cela fait 50 ans que les habitants
attendaient une vraie solution de
transport dans cette zone du département
les précisions avec catherine cela tôt
et patrick jacques de dixmude
et la voilà qui roule la première rame
du tramway entre châtillon et viroflay
sort du site de maintenance implantée à
vélizy pour un essai un moment que les
responsables qualifie d' historique
puisqu'il s'est agit de créer un nouveau
mode de transport de a à z et d'offrir
une gare à vélizy car ce pôle économique
avec 20000 habitants et 40000 emplois en
étaient dépourvus c'est un moment
historique
d'aucuns l'ont rappelé c'est un projet
qui a plus de 50 ans au moment où on a
vraiment conçu ce projet qui était lié
d'ailleurs à la au développement
économique de vélizy et pour la partie
blinois c'est un projet qui a pu être
menée tambour battant et il faut
rappeler que la partie chinoise on a
toujours tendance à croire que la partie
hauts de seine est plus important n'est
pas tellement 7 kilomètres et demi à
travers les hauts-de-seine et 6
kilomètres et demi sur les yvelines une
réalisation complexe va voir le jour 11
km 21 stations et des pentes importantes
pour relier viroflay un vrai défi
technologique
ce projet a été très compliqué à monter
les choix technologiques qui ont été
faits il ya déjà fort longtemps étaient
des choix un peu audacieux avec un
tramway sur pneus à grand gabarit qui
n'existait pas il a fallu fallu
concevoir un très beau et nouveau
spécialement pour cette ligne encore un
peu de patience pour voir ce t600
service 2014 pour la partie en surface
et 2015 pour la section souterrain coût
du projet 384 millions d'euros pour les
ouvrages et 134 millions d'euros pour le
matériel roulant
mardi après-midi vaste opération de
contrôles routiers lancé par la ddsp
soixante dix huit sur tout le territoire
pour lutter contre l'insécurité routière
nous avons l'occasion de suivre ces
barrages de police à coignières le
reportage d'olivier maniscalco et les
images de patrick jacques de dixmude
jaloux travail 14h - 10 et je me suis
fait interpeller donc j'avais pas de ma
carte grise n'était pas à jour une
amende de 90 euros est théoriquement
immobilisation du véhicule mais j'ai
réussi un petit peu négocier avec eux
donc ils laissent repartir avec mon
véhicule pour romain la sanction est
tombée mais la vingtaine de contrôles
routiers de ce mardi après-midi dans les
yvelines était plutôt là pour rassurer
il en place par la ddsp 78 l'objectif
reste de lutter contre l'insécurité
routière il ya des gens qui roulent sans
permis sans assurance puis voilà quoi et
puis avoir des dangers sur la route ils
ont ils font leur boulot c'est normal on
voit que la maréchaussée et la éveil
alors bon respect des règles tout à fait
ça peut être rassurant quelque part
alcoolémie stupéfiants papiers du
véhicule plaques d'immatriculation
abîmés ou pare chocs accidenté les
arrêts de véhicules se succèdent et la
police vérifie que tout est bien en
règle ce type de contrôle départementale
est généralisée et déjà mis en place
depuis en fait le mois la fin du mois de
juin le début du mois de juillet sur
l'ensemble du département est très
régulièrement actuellement de ce profil
plutôt une tendance à des problèmes de
deux défauts de maîtrise à des problèmes
de comportement dangereux ce qu'on
appelle un comportement dangereux
restèrent le portable au volant le
passage de ligne blanche au passage de
stop plus généralement cas là que
limiter la vitesse sur près de 1000
véhicules contrôlés hier 80 infractions
ont été relevées et quatre personnes
placées en garde à vue pour rappel la
route a connu 3645 morts en 2012
l'objectif de l'état est de passer sous
la barre des 2000 personnes tuées en
jusqu'à vendredi les élèves des écoles
élémentaires de trappes participé à la
semaine du goût au menu des produits
issus de l'agriculture biologique avec
pour objectif de sensibiliser forcément
à cette cuisine équilibrée et de qualité
qu'on goûte et pour nous en tout ni h et
jonathan vilma
du potage de potiron un filet de hoki
avec un mélange de chou fleur voilà un
menu raffiné que les enfants de l'école
jean cocteau découvre avec quelques
hésitations devant l'assiette
le brocoli c'est du chou-fleur
danger
pendant toute la semaine ces élèves
trappistes mangent des produits bio
locaux sous forme de jeu ils apprennent
l'importance des fruits et légumes et
d'un menu équilibré
mais à la maison leurs plats préférés
restent bien loin de cette cuisine
diététique
la semaine du goût tente d'inciter les
enfants à une alimentation de qualité
car à la cantine gare aux petits
gourmets qui ne finit pas son assiette
on est environ entre 90 et 120 grammes
par enfant de rejet de produits de qui
est consommée sur 800 grammes à peu près
de produits par enfant c'est d'arriver à
au phénomène du groupe allaient bouger
ces phénomènes de groupe un enfant qui
dit j'en veux pas et les autres qui les
a bien joué moi non plus au vu des
assiettes vides ce repas dit d'automne a
tout de même plus aux enfants qui n'ont
pas laissé les miettes
et pour terminer ce journal je vous
propose de re découvrir l'image du jour
si vous n'étiez pas avec nos débuts de
cette édition c'est la fermeture
annoncée de lancer un bricorama montigny
le bretonneux la direction indique être
victime de la concurrence notamment de
l'enseignent leroy merlin le dimanche
situés sur le même secteur à bois d'arcy
une autorisation et dominical pour ce
magasin que n'a pas bricorama magasins
de centre ville à bricorama montini
perdait 100 mille euros par mois selon
le président du groupe fin de ce journal
a retrouvé en replay sur notre site
internet je vous retrouve jeudi en
direct toujours à 18h pour l'actualité
culturelle ce soir c'est avec aurélia de
bissy et kiosques bonne soirée sûreté
des fils
ici